welcome to pi day 20
2021
for
for my top for the top for doris lee's
talk doris
recently finished her phd
at rise lab in school of information at
uc berkeley the focus of her research is
design tools that make data exploration
and visualization easier and more
accessible
during this time she developed several
data science and visualization tools
aimed at accelerating
insight and
discovery
including lex the python library for
accelerating and simplifying the process
of data exploration
which is the focus to this talk today
since this is doris's time i'll i'll let
her take off
cool um hi everyone my name is doris lee
and as steven mentioned i recently
finished my phd at berkeley where i
worked on building tools that makes it
easier for people to visualize and
explore their data and i'm super excited
to speak at thai data global today to
share our work on lux which is a tool
that automatically helps you visualize
your pandas data frames
so
many of you at pi data global probably
already know about pandas and how it's a
tremendously popular tool for data
analysis and pandas is really awesome
because it comes with this intuitive and
convenient set of apis to let users play
around with their data and get quick
interactive feedback
and pandas is especially useful because
because of this convenient set of
utilities to help data scientists load
clean transform and analyze their data
and so when you're exploring your data
visualization is also a very
easy way for users to ask questions
about their data and learn from the
interesting patterns and trends that
emerge and in terms of how this is
actually done in practice
this is similar to what we see on the
left hand side here where data
scientists would write panda's code and
use some additional libraries
in a jupiter notebook environment to be
able to experiment and explore their
data
but even though the pandas data frame
comes with a very wide range of
functionalities and operations it's
often not easy to figure out what
exactly you need to do and what is the
steps of the analysis
you need to get to these insights so
let's take for example let's say a
simple task such as visualizing this bar
chart there's still a very high
effort that is required to visualize
your data programmatically so first for
example we need to think about you know
what this visualization should look like
what graphical encodings and mark we
should choose is it going to be a bar
chart or is it going to be a scatter
plot
and then we also need to think about you
know how do we process this data
correctly to plot this visualization
and then once we figure all of that out
we need to translate all these
specification details into code and on
the right hand side here what i'm
showing is examples of
just two examples of the amount of code
that is necessary to generate a single
visualization in um that we see on the
left so this is based on matplotlib and
plotly which has two very popular um
python visualization libraries
so oftentimes what happens is the sheer
amount of programming effort that's
required for visualizations often
hinders data exploration and this is
true especially in the early phases of
data exploration where you're just
kind of getting an overview of the data
and the users have a vague idea of what
they're looking for in terms of insights
and so to address these pain points what
we've done is we've developed a
lightweight visualization tool on top of
the pandas data frame called lux and the
goal of lux is to make it easier for
data scientists to explore their data by
automatically recommending useful and
relevant visualizations to the users
so without doing too much talking what
i'm gonna do is i'm going to jump into a
quick demo to showcase uh some of the
capabilities in lux
and if you're interested you could also
check out this website which has the
full uh notebook for the demo but i'm
gonna
screen share and show um show the
notebook here
okay so what i have loaded up here is
is a jupiter notebook
with uh
with some you know some
commands in uh lux and um
with lux loaded so in order to use lux
all you have to do is you can do this
import lux statement alongside your uh
import panda statement and when i
load in lux what i can do is i can use
any of the
familiar pandas api that i'm already
using so for example in this case i'm
using pd.read csv to load in a data
frame
and
so so far everything still looks exactly
the same as pan does except that we have
this additional import lux statement so
what happens when we print out the data
frame let's say we want to get a sense
of like what does my data look like when
i print out my data frame what i get is
the default pandas table that is being
shown to me so these
these
kind of highlight that there are rows
and columns in the data sets each row in
the data set corresponds to a country
now lux also adds this additional toggle
button which allows me to go from the
table view
and toggle to a dashboard of
visualizations that is recommended to
the users and this is super useful as a
visual view of looking at your table so
these are things these
dashboards showcase things like
correlations so that all the
visualizations here are ranked based on
ones that are most correlated to the
ones that are least correlated so you
can see that these patterns are a lot
more scattered
um we could also take a look at all the
univariate distribution so these are all
the
attributes in my data sets and these are
ranked based on the ones that are most
skewed to the ones that are more uniform
and less skewed
we could also look at occurrences and
even geographical maps showing
some of the values that are within my
data frame
and we can see that this is a very
useful way to get very quick visual
insights
beyond what we're seeing uh with the
default pandas table view
and so let's say that we're looking at
this data set and we notice that there's
a very interesting relationship between
the average life expectancy across
different countries and its inequality
index in particular there's kind of this
negative correlation across these two
variables
and
so we think that this is kind of
interesting we want to learn more and in
lux there's this concept of a high-level
intent so users can convey to lux hey
i'm interested in these variables show
me something that is related to that so
the way that we express this in lux is
we we would set df dot intent equals to
inequality and average life expectancy
so once we set this intent and we print
out the data frame again again we get
this default view that that we see in
pandas and then when we toggle to the
visualizations what we actually see is
the visualization that is based on our
intent so the average life expectancy
and inequality
now beyond this visualization lux also
shows me all the ones that are related
to this visualization so for example i
can add an additional attribute so
adding a column to look at you know how
this distribution changes how this
relationship changes when whether a
country is landlocked or not whether a
country is in a g10 country or not
maybe
depending on the region so i can add an
additional
column to look at how this visualization
breaks down
the other thing i could look at is i can
add an additional filter to what i
specified as the intent so i look i can
look at different subsets of the data so
for example
countries that are in the middle east
countries that have you know three
borders or countries that have um a
specific number of official languages so
these are really interesting breakdowns
of the
current visualizations that i've
specified
and then the final thing that you can
kind of take a look at is you can take a
step back and just look at the
univariate distributions that are in my
data set
so this this high level intent is a very
easy way for me to specify at high level
hey i'm interested in these attributes
show me something that's interesting
and one of the things you probably
already noticed is that lux doesn't
actually require any changes to your
pandas code so
what that means is that it makes it very
easy to do data manipulation and
visualizations all in the same
environment whereas typically you might
have to go to a separate bi tool or a
charting tool like excel or tableau to
be able to do the plots and then doing
the cleaning data cleaning and
manipulation within your notebook all of
the pandas api
can be used as is in in lux so here what
i've done is i've loaded in the covet
data set and i um i joined it with my
original data frame and when i print out
the df again we could see that those
additional columns are being added um
and the visualizations are updated right
away
so one of the interesting findings uh
that i that i see is that when i look at
my dashboards um there is a very
interesting trend uh between sort of the
the stringency scores
that is shown in this data set
and so
let's say that i wanted to share this
with a colleague this is an interesting
trend so i i what i can do is i can
click on this visualization
and i can click on the export button on
the top right hand side what this
actually does is that it allows me to
export this visualization um into a
programmatic variable so
i can access this variable by doing
df.exported
and this is the same visualization that
i've selected here
and this is really convenient now
because i have programmatic access
to this this visualization which means
that i can actually print it out as code
written in altair or matplotlib or vega
light so right now what i'm showing is
the map plotline
sorry the the altair code
and what i can then do is just copy and
paste this into a different cell and be
able to plot the exact same
visualization that i saw in
my
my dashboard
so this is super useful because
sometimes maybe i want to make some
tweaks to the visualization maybe i want
to add an additional
labels and titles and this is
i can do all of that with the alt care
code
and and then share this with a colleague
so that's at a very high level how you
can use lux to go from a simple
data frame which is
which
which uh that which you're working with
in pandas uh to a set of visualizations
that are recommended
um all the way to
visualization code that you can export
and then send to a colleague
okay
so going back to uh the talk um some of
you might wonder like okay how how how
does lux work how is it actually uh what
what is it actually doing underneath the
hood
so for that
lux is actually based on my dissertation
work where i've studied how to better
design automated assistance that helps
with
data analysis and visual data
exploration and lux is a culmination of
that research into a tool that is
lightweight usable and fits well within
the python and jupiter ecosystem um so
we've published a couple papers on this
topic and so if you're interested in the
details of how this is done underneath
the hoods and some of the optimizations
that we've developed to make this
scalable
feel free to check out the paper at this
link
so
just to kind of recap in the demo we saw
how a very uh typical data analysis
workflow where we're working with data
frames within the jupyter notebook can
be completely transformed by just adding
a simple import statement and with lux
working with data frames suddenly now
affords a lot more visual richness
to encourage these meaningful
exploration
and in particular when we print out the
data frames in lux
lux automatically recommends these
visualizations essentially for free to
the users and providing an alternative
way that
that the data frames can be visualized
and the visualization is always on in
the sense that users can always toggle
back and forth between these
complementary views
and sometimes we find that there are
tasks that are more amenable in this
table view whereas in other cases
the recommended visualizations might be
more useful for getting a quick overview
of the data set
we also saw in the demo how we're able
to do this while preserving the exact
same pandas api and commands
that you would typically use which means
that all the nice uh apis or
functionalities that you get from canvas
we could still
get in lux without having to change a
single line of code
and
this also means that we don't have to
move into a separate environment for
data cleaning or transformation and
visualizations
we also saw how data frames can be
attached to an intent which enriches the
data frame with signals about how the
visualization should be displayed to
users so users can specify at a very
high level
what they're interested in and lux
automatically infers the underspecified
details and determine the visualization
mappings based on best practices
finally we also saw how the users can
either
export their entire data frame
visualization into an interactive report
so lux currently work with dashboarding
tools like panel or streamlit
and some of the other tools that we saw
earlier today
you can also as we show in the demo
click on one or more visualizations and
then export them as code
you can edit these code further in your
jupyter notebook so lux currently
supports
vegalite altair and matplotlib as the
code that it generates and
so at this point you're probably
thinking lux is amazing how do i get
started and to get started uh you can
follow the readme on our github page and
lux is a simple one-line install that is
available on pip and conda
you can also
we follow the different setup
instruction where we support various
different notebook friends including
jupyter lab the classic jupiter notebook
as well as the s code
so to kind of recap in this talk we've
seen how lux is an automatic tool that
supports visualization and discovery
alongside a data frame workflow and so
we hope that this presentation gives you
a taste of how lux can help you enhance
your data exploration experience in the
notebook through a very low barrier way
of working with visualizations you can
find the source code and the
installation instructions on our github
page
cool and with that i'm happy to take any
questions with the remaining time
uh yeah we've got someone with a couple
uh
okay first one what's the pr
oh and another one popping in awesome
we've got pl we've got plenty of time so
feel free to ask away
uh what's the performance of lux say if
i have a data frame of 1000 columns and
1 million rows
yeah that's a really great question i
sort of alluded to this in oops let me
pull up this slide here
um and sort of this research slide um
where we actually did a lot of work on
making sure that um the computation of
the visualizations and all the things
that is required for generating these
recommendations is kept as a minimal
overhead um so currently like for medium
medium to large data sets there's still
a couple seconds of like wait time um
especially in the cases where there are
these very wide tables because you you
would imagine for example a thousand
columns you would actually have to um
iterate over all of these different
columns and combinations of them so it
quickly the the computation speak
quickly sort of adds up this particular
paper that i mentioned we've developed
three optimization strategies and we've
actually shown some experiments on how
it scales for these different
numbers of rows and different numbers or
columns so i would highly encourage if
you're interested in
looking at the scalability of this tool
to uh to look at that paper
all right thank you
a second one from the same person
another question does lux maintain state
if underlying data frame changes will
previous plots auto update
yeah that's a really great question so
this is tied in with the idea that um
we
we don't necessarily compute
the recommendations every single time as
your data frame changes this is one of
the optimizations that we exploit we
only compute that when you print out the
data frame so when you request for the
recommendations um so
the the plots do get updated um but only
it's doing this in a very efficient way
so that um it doesn't it doesn't have to
constantly recompute if you're not uh
printing out your data frame
there's a question around
uh how do you compare this with
something like trifacta
by jason
um
so that's actually a really great
question i i think that um there's many
many of these questions around like okay
how does this compare to you know a tool
like trifecta or tableau or some of the
other tools i think lux isn't intended
to be a replacement of um of these tools
um and like trifacta and tableau they
obviously have much richer support for
these visual interactions and
dashboarding capabilities the goal of
lux is to kind of get you to these quick
insights and then you can kind of delve
in further you could build a dashboard
around it so i see them as kind of a
complementary tool um instead of kind of
a replacement for
some of these graphical user interfaces
or low code no code tools
[Music]
um
all right if you want to take any more
there's a oh now they're starting to
roll in
on the technical side are you
monkey patching the data frame
yeah um so yeah on the technical side
how this is actually done under the
underneath the hoods is that um
we
luxe is monkey patching uh the pandas
data frame and we actually have this
internal object called the lux data
frame and it essentially is a wrapper
around uh the pandas data frame in some
sense and this is this is something that
we experimented uh quite a bit uh to
figure out what is the best way to
allow users to print out the data frame
and then be able to get all the
recommendations but still preserve all
the pandas api and the ability to use
that
all right uh
i'll go ahead with just a couple more
if you don't mind what can i do if i
have a visualization in mind that isn't
among the recommended charts
export code then modify it
yeah that's a really great question so
the goal of lux is again to get you to
these initial visualizations but we do
have some customization capabilities um
related to
creating additional tabs that you might
be interested in seeing we also have
this very expressive language we we saw
a little bit of that with the intent so
that you can specify at a high level hey
here are the columns that i'm interested
in and the lux has an internal
logic to help you generate the
visualization that is relevant to those
um so we actually have the capability of
creating this visualization or
collections of visualizations uh with
with that language without having to
write too much code so it's definitely
something that's
if you're interested uh
we we talk about this in our
documentation happy to follow up with
some of those links
oh yeah it looks like everyone's brains
are starting to get working now and uh
for sure you're i think your work is
really important because like one of the
heavy themes of the
conference promotion was ethics and ai
and
for that for that we need people like
you to actually make the data
understandable
to everyone
but yeah thank you very much and uh
everyone can follow up a few on your
links you provide or
thank you so much